he's big and Burly but identifies as
girly
yeah he changed his race and gender but
critics say he's a pretender yes it's
time for
me
and you don't like what you see
right in Maryland
[Music]
[Applause]
new name
a return
will be the same
if you've got a feeling oh there's
something you would like
to just switch your pronouns out refuse
to switch them back
[Music]
well done Gene
you get to stay another day that's
pretty good I gotta say so check out
Indiana Councilman Ryan Webb he's a gun
toting American loving stotch Republican
white dude who says he's now a
transgender lesbian woman of color
yes he checks more boxes than a clerk at
Foot Locker
you get that you know when they go back
and they look for your size it's
checking boxes
see now you get it it's kind of cute
isn't it
he's in the running cabinet post and all
I can say is you go girl
and by Go I mean go standing up at a
urinal
quote identify as a woman and not just
any woman but as a woman of color I
guess this would make me gay slash
lesbian as well since I'm attracted to
women until today we didn't have any
females of color or lgbtqia PC Plus Plus
on the council I'm glad that now we do
well said he also told us he's gotten a
lot of hate intolerance racism and
bigotry from the political left but the
reaction is being dwarfed by messages of
love and support can you use dwarf as a
verb
I don't know if I like that
would you like it if we used you as a
verb
but I wonder if Webb is being dead
serious and this isn't a joke
I'm being dead serious
this isn't a joke I said what I said
I don't know what to tell you you don't
get to question me you do not diction
require proof from me you were part of
the movement to help establish these
rules and set the bar he's got a point
there right it's just giving the left a
taste of their own medicine except this
time those meds aren't puberty blockers
being fed to confused kids
and despite his new identity Webb said
he'll retain his preferred he him
pronouns and his penis
that way he can still compete in women's
swim Sports
thank you
dad isn't this a solution to this kind
of self-identification Hysteria is just
jump right into the pool and get wet I'm
already way ahead of this guy so in my
last book The parasitic mind I argued
that I should be allowed to enter a
under eight Judo competition using
transism and transgravity because I
self-identified seven-year-old boy who's
63 pounds that more recently I I also
reported that there's a new thing called
transgenderism by proxy let's suppose
I'm a gay man who only sleeps with men
but I feel conflicted about that let's
say My Religion makes me feel bad about
that
I could self-identify the men that I've
slept with as women and therefore I'm a
strict heterosexual and thirdly I
recently came out of the proverbial
closet as a gay man because my
biological woman wife with whom I've
been married for 23 years and she has
we've had children together she
self-identifies as a man and so I stand
before you right here as a proud gay man
oh very good congratulations
[Applause]
I think Jason that I I think that we get
to we should be able to identify as
specific people who are already have an
identity but who's to say I can't be you
know uh George Clooney
why not I think adults can be whatever
they want as long as they don't ask me
to pay for it yeah as long as you don't
ask me to believe in it you know and
this guy's about to shoot his off
did you see this gun no
trans himself
that's not where you keep it you're
right that's not where you get it done
like this is about to be funnier yeah
exactly that would be an unintentional
punch line to this story he shoots his
wiener off I'm making a comeback yeah we
don't condone that sort of behavior here
on this show I want you to keep your
wieners intact
well to make it real easy to identify
him yes that is true
um cat what do you make of this story I
know that this is like this is you know
I I this isn't really new uh other
people are doing it now we had the
Canadian woman right the uh that we
haven't talked about her in like two
weeks what's her uh the shop teacher
Kayla lamu oh I have no idea what you're
talking about oh yes you do
she is like yeah knockers are the size
of Trinidad and Tobago well we talked
about this about how if Kayla happened
to be a troll and then they just played
into it and it didn't work what could
have happened here if everybody was just
like okay
then this wouldn't be this massive thing
yes obviously did it for attention and
he has six kids
so he probably never gets attention
like at least two of the kids have to be
like Dad you know because
I'm sure he's got to be a fan this isn't
necessarily a new thing people say stuff
like this all the time yeah and he got a
lot of attention if people would have
just said okay sure but instead of
saying that like he's making people
unsafe or threat it's like no it's like
kind of a a joke essentially that people
have told before which is a lot
different than putting someone in a
position of being not safe if people
just said yes ma'am then it would have
been a completely different story it's a
it's it's a uh a kind of a where a joke
becomes performance art which is
oftentimes the best kind of joke Emily
have you ever thought about like
identifying as something other like
anything like if you could what would
you identify as
a woodland like a unicorn type you know
you could I mean there are people that
do identify as uh My Little Ponies
that's right that's right I would like
to say this he is totally right I love
him so much so he went on to say I'm
just glad that this is now possible so
anyone can be anything or anyone they
want who knows just how far we can take
things he's absolutely right that's the
whole point and for him to get this
backlash calling him pathetic saying
you're making a mockery of us what was
Dylan Mulvaney doing exactly Woman face
why why isn't that a mockery of me why
if someone puts on lipstick prances
around in a backyard pretends to be a
cheerleader how is that not mocking
every biological female so you can just
put on a dress and all of a sudden you
know what you know what that identity is
like you appreciate the gravitas of my
gender so I love that he's calling them
out and I think what what also to your
point about being you know how how do
you know who means it that's why he's
like you actually have no right to
question me because we have no right
according to the left to question any of
that exactly so one of the transgender
online Charlize James said a transgender
resident in his town says his words
embarrass himself and you as well the
County Council I'm assuming we can't
question her no I'm assuming by her
identification that oh yep she means it
and he doesn't that's absolutely
unacceptable and it shows and belies how
false this is yeah and I don't know that
bovaney just said that she believes that
people who criticize her should be
arrested I don't know if you saw that
that's horrible yeah that's scary it is
scary good point cat no it is okay
I actually write about this in my book
that Free Speech historically
marginalized communities are the biggest
supporters of it because they're the
ones who have needed it the most so
everyone from abolitionists to women's
rights activists to gay rights activists
have understood that so Dylan Mulvaney
is saying oh these people in government
are transphobic everyone's transphobic
so let's let these people now control
what people can say I don't stand how
you can get from that point to that
point without realizing that you're
actually maybe going to really hurt
yourself amen all right up next or a
woman
federal agents got confused and a poor
man got abused hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else